what if Superman was in Game of Thrones
it seems like fans are going to Great
Lengths to make that very thing happen
in a way at least Henry Cavill is
someone who is well aware of the Game of
Thrones and The Witcher comparisons that
have been floating around the internet
for years now and thanks to the fan
artist bosslogic we can actually see
what the star looks like as a descendant
of valyria and its epic back in December
2019 at the height of the Targaryen talk
and ahead of The Witcher season one
Henry told Entertainment Tonight I think
comparisons are always going to be made
and it's fun it's fine when there are
two ends of a spectrum in a fantasy
genre appearing on Jimmy Kimmel Live
that same month Castle jokingly told the
late night host I modeled myself after
Khaleesi I made people call me Khaleesi
or Amelia on set I want to be Amelia or
Khaleesi call me Mother of Dragons I'm
fine it's no secret that Henry is a huge
fan of fantasy and fiction whether it be
books movies television shows Comics or
video games boss logic and other fan
artists have imagined him in a number of
different franchises and famous forms
including Wolverine and James Bond but
seeing Cavill as a Targaryen May truly
be the most incredible Hide Your Dragons
folks because Henry Cavill is officially
here as a member of House Targaryen
boss logic shared the awesome fan
casting in late August through his
social media channels
on the post the Creator joked the hair
checks out this is in reference to
cavill's similar silver hairstyle in The
Witcher boss logic's image of Cavill was
accompanied by a house of the Dragon
Banner at the bottom which debuted in
August 2022 and seemingly inspired him
franchise fans and viewers have been
eating the fan casting up with many
calling for Studio execs to take notice
one Twitter user wrote Henry Cavill
would make a badass aegon the Conqueror
or young jaharis adult aegon the fifth
Baylor the Blessed aegon the Unworthy in
his early years just give caval a cool
Targaryen role someone else tweeted what
other man would we deem worthy to cast
as writer of valerion the black dread a
dragon so large it could swallow a fully
armored Knight on Horseback with one
snatch of its Mighty jaw wielding the
mighty Valerian blade blackfyre I see no
other choice he's my aegon that all said
what makes the caval fan casting truly
epic for Game of Thrones and House of
the Dragon fans is the fact that Cavill
isn't just some George R.R Martin novice
for those who aren't aware Henry Cavill
is someone who is not only a fan of the
Game of Thrones HBO series but also the
books that inspired it in fact he's even
managed to convince others in Hollywood
to read them and was able to pass on his
fandom to at least one of his previous
co-stars Lawrence Fishburne conlith Hill
A Game of Thrones actor and family
friend of Lawrence explained in an
interview with vulture he was about to
watch the show and Henry Cavill was the
one who told him no no no read the books
first so he became a fan of A Song of
Ice and Fire all the Game of Thrones
books he's read them all and then
Fishburne's wife showed me a text from
Lawrence that said welcome master of
Whisperers and your little birds too or
something like that which was very sweet
of both of them back in April 2021
Cavill posted a photo online that showed
him playing a game of thrones chess set
with his girlfriend a Twitter user
responded he shouldn't be playing on a
Game of Thrones chess set he should have
been playing on Game of Thrones with
House of the Dragon already appearing to
be a major hit for HBO it's not
completely out of the question for
Cavill to appear on the show one day as
a Targaryen only time will tell
[Music]